I'm going to play a clip for you a Fox
News propagandist Laura Ingraham
casually mentioning before a commercial
break oh this story about uh vets being
thrown out of hotels to put in illegals
turns out the story was completely false
don't know why anybody would make it up
we'll talk to you later see you on
tomorrow's show very casually saying
that entire story my whole network
covered for days
turns out it was made up
it happened so quickly you might not
even notice it listen to this all right
before we go a little update on a story
we brought you this week about homeless
vets being displaced from hotels so that
illegals could move in turns out the
group behind the claim made it up
we have no clue as to why anyone would
do such a thing but we'll bring you any
updates should they come
that is that this is crazy stuff guys
this is really really crazy we ran
stories non-stop for a week based on no
sourcing on a total lie and we got
caught
we don't know why anyone would make this
up because they got you to cover it
Laura this is the entire point the the
false naivete
why would anyone make up a story that
makes Biden look bad and undocumented
immigrants look bad and makes veterans
appear to be the victims of undocumented
immigrants why would anyone make that up
well it's because this is what your
network traffic's in Laura uh some other
guy also issued this retraction was like
Mar this one was 30 seconds instead of
20 seconds quick update on a story from
earlier this week about homeless
veterans being displaced from a hotel in
Newburgh New York to make room for
migrants we're now looking into new
reports that a veterans Advocate misled
lawmakers about or and media Outlets
about a story that some homeless men may
have been hired to pose as veterans that
the equivocation we're looking into some
claims that maybe someone else lied and
it's possible like the entire thing was
a complete hoax meant to fire people up
we've reached out to the Organization
for a statement but so far have not
heard back we'll send it back to you
yeah there's enough chaos with that
potentially false stories running around
out there yeah we it's too chaotic out
there for false stories to be running
around unchecked which we do all the
time which we do all the time there's a
Daily Beast article that sums this up
Fox News stoked outrage over migrants
displacing homeless vets it was a hoax
Fox News and the rest of right-wing
media went wild for a week over a now
debunked story about New York hotels
booting homeless vets to accommodate
Asylum Seekers this is what they do and
the false innocence we can't imagine why
why would anyone make this up well why
did people make things up about Hillary
and Obama and Biden and Hunter Biden and
whistleblowers that don't exist this is
what they do to try to convince people
to come to their political side and this
is the equivalent of a week of page on
newspaper headlines and then a Sunday
retraction on page B12
uh it's it's the same thing a week of
headlines headlines headlines the five
with a big Blockbuster discussion who is
really the worst person involved in this
situation where vets are being kicked
out to put undocumented immigrants in
they don't call them undocumented
immigrants by the way and then oh real
quick before we go it's 9 59 and 40
seconds now uh before we go that uh
story seems someone made it up we don't
know why but uh we'll look into it
anyway and of course only a fraction of
the audience sees the retraction and the
cycle continues and continues Laura
Ingram and the entire network should be
ashamed of themselves particularly in
the midst of hundreds of millions of
dollars in lawsuits actually billions in
lawsuits with nearly a billion in
settlements so far over untrue things
that they have said
disgusting and the Casual nature with
with which they do the retraction is
just like the cherry on top or the
bottom of the barrel or call it what you
will one of our sponsors today is Bon
charge I have always enjoyed dry saunas
you get in there your heart rate is up
dilates the blood vessels can soothe
achy joints and muscles it's relaxing
it's just a great way to remove a little
stress Bon charge is the creator of the
infrared sauna blanket which you can
enjoy from home super easy to set up
heats up fast you don't have to have
your head inside like at a traditional
sauna at the gym nice for meditating or
reading getting work done relaxing I
have found it to be a great way to
unwind at the end of a long day easy to
clean Sleek lightweight design easy to
store and comes with a 12 month warranty
and of course if you don't love it
returns are super easy but I think you
will love it and you'll get 15 off when
you go to boncharge.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down down
below